نقلت شبكه سي انان عن المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي قوله ان
واشنطن تعتقد ان مجموعه كتائب حزب الله
المدعومه من ايران هي التي تقف وراء هجوم
الاحد في الاردن واكد كوربي ان الولايات
المتحده سترد على الهجوم في الوقت المناسب
والطريقه المناسبه وان الرئيس بايدن سيقوم
بمراجعه الرد المناسب الذي سيتم اتخاذه في
المستقبل واضاف كوربي ان واشنطن لا تريد
استمرار هذه الهجمات غير المقبوله وستفعل
ما يتعين عليها القيام به لحمايه قواتها
ومنشات ومصالح امنها القومي في المنطقه
كما شدد المسؤول الامريكي على ان بلاده لا
تسعى الى حرب مع ايران ولا تريد توسيع
نطاق الصراع في الشرق
الاوسط وكانت واشنطن قد اعلنت مقتل ثلاثه
عسكريين امريكيين واصابه اربعه
في هجوم بطائره مسيره قالت انها استهدفت
القوات الامريكيه شمال شرقي الاردن قرب
الحدود مع سوريا وقال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن في بيان ان الهجوم نفذته جماعات
متشدده مدعومه من ايران تعمل في سوريا
والعراق واضاف ان ادارته تجمع المعلومات
عن هذا الهجوم وان قلب امريكا مثقل بمقتل
جنودها واكد بايدن في بيانه ان واشنطن
ستحاسب كل المسؤولين عن هذا الحادث
وبالطريقه التي تختارها وانها ستحافظ على
الالتزام المقدس تجاه عائلات الضحايا
وبمكافحة
عمل جار من اجل تحديد هويه المجموعه
المسلحه التي هاجمت القوات الامريكيه في
الاردن وقال مسؤولون في البنتاجون ان
الهجوم استهدف موقعا توجد فيه قوات
امريكيه تعرف باسم البرج 22 شمال شرقي
الاردن وان هذه القوات تقدم مشوره ومساعده
لنظيرتها في
الاردن معنا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره صر
الحسيني ناصر نعود معك للتركيز على ابرز
ما قاله جون
كيربي فيما يخص هذه الهجمات الولايات
المتحده كانت الى حد ما تتجاهل هذه
الهجمات المستمره على مدى اعوام ضد قواتها
س في سوريا والعراق طالما لم يسقط ضحايا
امريكيون هذه المره سقط ثلاثه جنود
امريكيون قتلى بالاضافه الى حوالي 30
اخرين مصابين وبالتالي هول ما هذا المشهد
اثر بشكل واضح في المستويات السياسيه داخل
الولايات المتحده واستمعنا قبل قليل جون
كربي المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض باسم
الامن القومي يتحدث عن مجموعه خيارات
سيتخذها الرئيس امامه عده خيارات اقترحت
عليه لكن البيت الابيض على ما يبدو غير
متحمس لضربه سريعه و للانتقام فقط يريد
ضربه تسير ترسل رسائل واضحه وراء موقف
البيت الابيض المتاني على ما يبدو ذلك
الجدل الان في الكون كونجرس مجموعه من
اعضاء الكونجرس وعلى راسهم الجمهوريون من
سقور
مثل السناتور من سوث كارولاينا لينزي جرام
الان يطالبون بالرد ولكن الرد ليس على
مستوى هذه المجموعات المسلحه من طرف ايران
كما تقول الولايات المتحده وانما بقصف
طهران بقصف مواقع داخل الاراضي الايرانيه
هذا الى حد ما جعل الرئيس بايدن يتانى في
رده والان البيت الابيض يؤكد قبل قليل فقط
بان الرد الامريكي اتن وقادم لا محاله لكن
لكن سيكون في الوقت وفي الظرف الذي تختاره
الولايات المتحده ضد من هذا غير معروف هل
سيتم استهداف اراضي امريكيه اراضي ايرانيه
معذره هذا لا يبدو الامر كذلك لان كربي
يقول يؤكد مجددا لا نريد هذه المواجهه مع
ايران لا نريد توسيع هذه الحرب وبالتالي
البيت الابيض الان ورغم الصبد هنا وهناك
يستعد لضربه قادمه ضد احدى المجموعات ربما
كتائب حزب الله ربما كتائب المقاومه
الاسلاميه لا حدا يعلم بالضبط لكن الراي
الامريكي الرد الامريكي اتن ولا محاله بعد
دقائق بعد ايام بعد اسابيع لا احد يعلم
لكنه ات ولا شك على الرئيس الامريكي ان
يرد على الاقل لاسكات منتقديه داخل
الولايات المتحده وهو في هذه الفتره
الانتخابيه يتعرضوا للكثير من الانتقادات
عليه التحرك ام اذا الرد قادم لا محاله
للرد الامريكي لكن دون توسيع نطاق الصراع
ودون الدخول او الرغبه في الدخول مع في
حرب مع ايران كيف يمكن فهم هذا الموقف
الامريكي وفي هذه المرحله التي يجري فيها
حاليا مراجعه هذا الرد
المرتقب نعم الولايات المتحده تدرك ان
هناك علاقه مباشره الان مع الحرب ضد
الفلسطينيين في غزه وما تراه الان على
الارض الولايات المتحده
كتحلية الحرب على الفلسطينيين في غزه وما
تعيشه الان الولايات المتحده من جبهات
فتحت بشكل مفاجئ جبهه مع انصار الله
الحوثيين والان هذه الجبهه ليس الجبهه
السوريه
العراقيه تفتح مجددا وباث قويه على الجانب
الامريكي ولذلك مجموعه ايضا من اعداء
الكونغرس لا يريدون التسرع نحو راس الافعى
كما تسمى في الولايات المطوح وهي ضرب
ايران للخروج من هذه الازمه وانما التاني
في الرد عدم ربط الرد العسكري الامريكي
بما يحدث في غزه والاقتصار على ربطه
بايران فقط ولذلك هناك مطالب ايضا بانه
اذا تمت المطالبه بدوله فلسطينيه وحل
الصراع الفلسطيني العربي الفلسطين العربي
ربما هذا سيكون سرا او مفتاحا لحل كل هذه
الازمات ولا تضطر الولايات المتحده ان
تنجر عسكريا كما يبدو الامر ذلك الى
صراعات مفتوحه سواء مع الجانب اليمني او
الجانب الايراني وبالتالي النقاش دائر
داخل الولايات المتحده والقرار بيد الرئيس
بايدن حقيقه كيف سيوجه دفه الامريكيين في
هذه الصرعات المرتبطه فيما بينها صراع
الصراع مفتوح الان على ما يبدو والولايات
المتحده على ما يبدو ايضا تتانى في الدخول
في اي مواجهه عسكريه مع ايران هي بحاجه
لايران في الموضوع النموي في بحاجه لايران
في موضوع المسالك الخليجيه والطرق البحريه
ولا تريد بالفعل ان تكون تلك المواجهه
وتنكسر اي اتصالات الايران امريكيه
وبالتالي تكون المواجهه مفتوحه نعم
بالتالي تاني الان في البيت الابيض فيما
يخص هذا الرد اشكرك جزيل الشكر نناصر
الحسيني مراسلنا من واشنطن وانوه